[Musique]
joyeux noël des enfants
moi je nomme je sais que vous avez tous
été gâté et que le père noël est venu
qu'est ce qu'il vous a apporté ou l'or
mais il est très gentil et nicolas et
pimprenelle ont-ils eu de beaux cadeaux
je vais voir ça patron europe pour le
sol n'oublie pas de leur dire nounours
que si hier soir c'était fait
ce soir on se couche de bonheur qu'on te
sur groix propos pourtant pompon
[Musique]
joyeux noël les enfants joyeux noël
voyez maintenant également bp ne s'est
montrée elle est créée le 2 juin que
deux joueurs mais qui vous apportez tout
ça t'inquiète là il a apporté dans la
cheminée d'un atelier vous en avez de la
chance
il ya ainsi des paquets qui ne sont pas
pour nourrir au voyons voir où on met
mes neveux ou s'ils ont eu de bons
cadeaux dh et 9ème la bd et des bonbons
au miel
les petits veinards regarde l'état
canaux voyons où qui est lourd celui là
monsieur nounours mais c'est pour moi et
l'eau mais il est adressé à mon patron
qui le gentil ce père noël moi j'ouvre
mon paquet là
[Musique]
attention à mon train de nous au de
lunettes de soleil qu'elle préside et
moi que les yeux si fragile et sa môman
du miel
[Musique]
piven consciente auto par rémy est ce
que c'est bon c'est vraiment un chic
type ce peur qu elle ne m'a pas fait mal
à un peu de miel qu'est ce qu'ils ont et
ne veut nous arrête pas que gratter
c'est une belle vie de l'habitude
allo petit rémi toto fait fort au dodo
quelle est la bible merci pas preneur à
soit sage enfants on ne sera plus
nicolas et pimprenelle bon vous chantez
votre petite berceuse pour vous en donne
n'est-ce pas nicolas et pimprenelle au
revoir mais chérubins votre tonton va
vite portés sont à quai ou marchand de
sable
bonne nuit les enfants à demain 1,90 à
demain
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes bien dans notre lit non non
vous fouette avant nuit farouche voix me
fait plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
non je vais m'endormir
chaque fois nous fait plaisir
merci le nours c'est le père noël qui
m'ont voit ce beau paquet oui pas trop
c'est le père noël c'est sûrement dû
chocolat gens voudraient bien mort fou
non demain gros gourmand allons fidèle
compagnon en route aux routes ou bonne
nuit les enfants à demain
à de bain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]